now I'm joined now by Lawrence holding
he is a British national 32 years old
and has just emerged from the pasture
hospital his having suffered injuries at
the hands of this terrorist Lawrence
first of all let me offer on behalf of
sky and all of our viewers a great deal
of thanks that you only only have
suffered what appeared to be relatively
light injuries considering but could you
walk us through so to speak what
happened to you last night well we've
been enjoying the the firework display
on the promenade des anglais which we
came last year as well and it's a
wonderful occasion all ages there all
nationalities or all races everybody
having a great time the five explained
just finished we were actually just
heading back to our apartment just
stopped to enjoy one of the bands that
was playing on the on the promenade and
then we turned to hear lots of commotion
and shrieking and shouting and then we
saw a truck coming down the promenade
probably 30 or 40 miles per hour
careering from side to side obviously
everybody was running and very concerned
about this we didn't know what to do so
we turned around as everybody else did
it would got quite close to us so we
decided to well I decided to jump over
the wall of the the promenade landed on
the concrete which is a bit bit further
down than I had anticipated heads and to
my wrist but we were very lucky so you
were you were literally forced off the
road and over a concrete wall into the
unknown yeah yeah and who we with with
my fiancee
is she okay yeah she's got a gash on her
leg but she's she's fine
now given the level of threat that
France has experienced the Charlie Hebdo
attack batter clan and so on did you
have any trepidation about coming here
to nice no no no more than we would have
going to any other major city obviously
I suppose Bastille days probably makes
her likely targets but we we had
have any fears over that we will see we
live in London so there's always a
constant worry about it but stay
vigilant but it was horrific absolutely
awful could you can you recall having
even seen the driver where you were
aware of him at all we were running away
it was it had but very quickly and we're
exactly on the promenade were you were
you quite close to where the vehicle
came to a standstill at the end no no we
were probably I don't know quite how far
it reached but we were outside the
Negresco hotel so it speeded past I
don't know how far I reached excuse me
sir actually went past you after you had
jumped over the wall did you lose
contact at that point with your fiance
Oh only momentarily see a panic couple
of moments but I was concerned that the
the the truck might come over the wall
at that point so it was I think we were
both running did you both go over the
wall together yeah so at least you were
aware of her presence close to you
because of course a large number of
people have been separated during this
this carnage after the this truck passed
what did you then see very little really
we were moved away from onto the beach
we started walking across the beaches
probably a few hundred people there and
then there was sound of some some
gunfire and there was a sense of panic I
suppose with other atrocities on beaches
or that have been in the past we were
quite conscious of that so we started
running but I think by that point it was
relatively far away and we just made our
way back to our apartment as quickly as
we could now you were nursing an injury
was it obvious what your injury was at
that time no I thought I'd sprained my
wrist but I as I said it was a lot of
adrenaline so I felt okay Catherine had
a nasty cut on her leg but we were
conscious that we should get back and as
you said at the start injuries were very
minor compared to many others so we felt
it was best to get to the apartment to
stay safe and then obviously come to the
little later today and where is
Catherine your fiancee now she's just
over there living I'm glad she's still
with you physically the the process
though that that you witnessed this
extraordinary site of a truck barreling
down the road
scattering people on other side when you
walked back what did you see did you see
the evidence of this trucks atrocities
yes the were there was debris and people
lying obviously seriously injured or
maybe even dead in the road and it was
quite unlike anything I've ever seen and
would hope to never see again were you
in a position to be able to offer any
help but was it much more question of
obeying what the authority said to get
off the street and get safe I'm afraid
though we were probably thinking more of
ourselves in and getting away from that
and maybe a shameful for us that we
weren't able to often want more help to
people that sir well they would have
been very little you could have done
with a broken wrist and a severe guest I
wouldn't feel bad about that yourselves
but nonetheless the what you saw on the
ground there is the sort of atrocity
that many people across Europe are
fearful of now that you've endured it
what would you have to say to others who
may face this in the future
I wouldn't wish it on anyone that's for
sure and I suppose I don't know I think
this it's so much that happens on
instinct when something whatever you
might plan to do for it is just kicks in
and you Iran